for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy next
up is ionization energy and we'll start
off with the definition ionization
energy is the amount of energy often
listed in kilojoules that is required to
completely remove one mole of electrons
from one mole of gaseous atoms or ions
okay
so here we've kind of have these sort of
the reaction definition right the
reaction that we actually see here this
is the reaction for the ionization
energy we start off with X which
represented symbol of some some atom
okay some element and it's initially
neutral at least in this case and we're
gonna take off an electron so we're
gonna have a lecture on freed-up over
here to the right you see that that
electron is freed up and what results is
that this initially neutral atom in the
gas form is now a gaseous ion
specifically it has a positive charge so
it is positively charged which is
actually pretty important to keep in
mind now the change in energy associated
with this reaction is the actual
ionization energy okay and in this case
it's called ionization energy one known
as the first ionization energy okay so
upon hearing that you're probably
thinking okay that must mean that a
second and third ionization energy and
we'll get to that shortly okay now the
change in energy associated with this
reaction the ionization energy is often
measured in kilojoules per mole it's a
positive value always okay and we'll get
to that in just a second okay so just as
an example here I want to show you four
for instance of for sodium if you start
off with sodium in the
she's warm we rip off an electron and we
get sodium plus and we get that free
electron the energy associated with that
is 500 kilojoules per mole okay so that
would be the ionization energy one the
first ionization energy for sodium okay
now the question is why is energy
required to make this happen okay we're
talking about pulling an electron away
from an atom's nucleus which is
positively charged right electrons are
negatively charged and are therefore
attracted to the nucleus the two the
electrons and the nucleus do not want to
be separated so if you want to pull them
apart if you want to take an electron up
a little way from something it's
attracted to you're gonna have to have
an input of energy and so that's why the
ionization energy is always positive so
I should actually note that here it's
always positive okay in fact required
kind of implies that okay now another
question is can the ion that results
from the ionization energy rack reaction
have its electrons removed from it well
assuming it has electrons left to be
pulled off then yeah that could happen
okay and now they would that look well
if we have this X plus in the gas form
and we rip off an electron
we'll have well losing another negative
charge so now we go from X plus 2 X 2
plus okay and that's another that's
still anion right now it's a more a more
positively charged ion now the change in
energy associated with this right the
energy required to make this happen
it's called the ionization energy number
two right because we're pulling off a
second electron okay so this is called
the second
and energy now the energy change
associated with that is going to be a
bigger positive value bigger than not
ionization energy number one ionization
energy number two is gonna be bigger
than ionization energy number one why is
that well it's gonna be harder to remove
an electron from a positively charged
species right initially we were taking
an electron we were taking an electron
away from a neutral atom right but now
we're taking a left Ron away from a
positively charged ion that's good
that's going to definitely be harder to
do right because the electron is
attracted to that positive charge it
doesn't want to leave so it's gonna
require more energy to pull it off
okay so thus more energy is required
okay and you might be thinking what
about the third fourth fifth ionization
energies well each successive ionization
energy requires more energy than the
previous ionization energy okay now
before we get into more about that let's
discuss the trend in the first
ionization energy ionization energy
number one okay we'll see how that looks
on the periodic table okay so the
question is what's the trend on the
periodic table as far as ionization
energy goes well it's gonna increase up
and to the right okay so one thing you
should notice is that this is the
opposite of the atomic size or atomic
radius trend which we talked about in
the previous video what does that mean
well it means that it's harder oops
hargh that's hilarious it's harder to
remove an electron from a smaller atom
right so remember atomic radius
increases down into the to the left
alright
ionization energy increases
is up in to the right so that's opposite
in both ways so increase is going up
this way right and also increase is
going across this way so we have that
the atoms with the or the elements with
the highest ionization energy will be up
in to the right where as the atomic
radius the largest would be that to the
bottom left smallest up top so it's
harder to remove an electron from a
smaller atom well why is that well when
an atom is smaller its electrons are
closer to be positively charged nucleus
and therefore the the the force between
the nucleus and the electrons is greater
because the electrostatic force in is
inversely related to the distance
between the charges so if these
electrons are if the electrons are
closer to the positively charged nucleus
then it's going to be harder to rip them
off so if you have a smaller atom the
ionization energy will be higher okay so
in short when you think about going down
a group the atomic size increases right
the electrons are farther away from the
nucleus right as you go down a group
atom size is bigger the electrons are
farther away from the nucleus so in that
case the electrons are easier to remove
so if they're easier to remove then the
ionization energy is lower right so
that's why the lowest ones are down to
the left
okay now across a period to the right
the atomic size decreases right due to
the increase in the effective nuclear
charge that we talked about in the
previous video so if the atomic size
decreases that means the electrons are
closer to the nucleus which means
they're more attracted and thus the
electrons will be harder to remove so if
they're harder to remove that means
there's a higher ionization energy
that's what we have at the top right
okay however there are exceptions okay
there are exceptions so this problem
asks us to explain the following
so basically asking us why does the
trend break here notice that if you have
a periodic table it might be useful to
look at but if you look at the top right
of the periodic table we've got boron
carbon nitrogen oxygen fluorine and neon
in the second row okay so we notice here
that as we pay attention to the trend
going from here to here increasing here
to here increasing here to here it's
kind of weird it decreases but here to
here increases here to here it increases
so generally it increases but there is
an exception we talked about this in the
intro about how the how this this is
just a trend right this is not an
end-all be-all sort of thing okay so the
question is why is this trend broken
here okay
attached to that question we should
think about the electron configuration
and the orbital diagrams okay so for
nitrogen the electron configuration is
the outer electron configuration is 2s2
2p3 right because it has the 1s - from
helium
first but the 2s2 2p3 so that would be
like this 2s2 2p3
okay so it is half filled like this
let's do this in pink so it's half
filled which is pretty stable right
because all of these electrons are in
separate orbitals they're all spinning
in the same direction far away from each
other
okay now if we have an i if we have the
ionization energy reaction sort of occur
we rip off one of these electrons and we
form the cation and plus then we have a
new electron configuration we have 2s2
2p2
right so we're gonna get rid of
basically this electron right here so
we're gonna have just 2s2 2p2
okay so here we ruined the half-filled
stable nature okay so we lost the
stability
of having a half filled orbitals so
that's that's not something that that
you know wants to happen right you don't
want to lose that stability now if we
think about oxygen oxygens electron
configuration is 2s2 2p4 after that
helium right the core electrons so we've
got to us 2 to P 1 to a little bit
closer to the right 1 2 3 4 and if we
rip off an electron we're gonna rip off
this one right oops that is not the one
that I wanted to do this one right here
we're gonna take that off so the O plus
ion would be helium 2s2 2p3
that's the configuration that nitrogen
has when it's half filled right so here
this is half filled and stable and here
it's not that this isn't stable but this
is not ideal having two electrons in the
same orbital right they that's that's
not a stable as having them half filled
okay now what we see here basically the
idea is that with nitrogen ruining that
HAP that stability of it being half
filled is gonna require a lot more
energy than it is going to to rip off
the electron for oxygen because oxygen
taking off this electron right here
actually results in a somewhat stable
configuration with these orbitals being
half filled okay so that is the reason
for this trend breaking here right
nitrogen
it's ionization energy its first
ionization energy is gonna be higher
than that of oxygen for this reason okay
so keep that in mind when you come
across potential exceptions later lit in
your studies rather
okay so we mentioned successive
ionization energies being higher earlier
right so ionization energy number one is
gonna be less than ionization energy
number two which is less than ionization
energy number three so as you go further
and further each successive ionization
energy is higher so the question is why
is that well pulling an electron from a
more positively charged species is going
to be harder right because those
negative leave those negatively charged
electrons are attracted to those
positive charges the more positive the
charges the more attracted the electron
is to it okay so we've already shown
what is a an energy wanted to look like
right
well ionization energy three what would
that look like well we would just have
to take off another electron from what
whatever just resulted from the
ionization energy to reaction so
ionization energy two we had the x2 plus
ion so that's what we'll start with an
ionization energy three right and we'll
rip off an electron and that'll result
in the x3 plus ion okay and then if we
want the ionization energy for that'll
be x3 plus taking off from electron two
resulting the x4 plus a simple way to
remember it is that if you want to know
what the reaction looks like which is
actually really really useful it's to
just keep in mind that ionization energy
number one will result in a +1 ion
ionization energy number two will result
in a +2 ion ionization energy three will
result in a +3 ion so on and so forth
alright now sometimes there are large
jumps in energy from one ionization
energy to the next okay so I just write
that here as ionization energy n2
ionization energy n plus one so from one
to the next sometimes the jump in the
requirement for energy is pretty pretty
pretty big so that's something to pay
attention to and I have an example of a
problem where that sort of situation is
involved so here it says a period two
element has the following ionization
energies so they give you this little
table so you have ionization energy one
through five and we can see that these
approximate values in kilojoules per
mole the first one is 801 then we go to
eight 2407 then two 3660 and then a huge
jump from the 3000
5,000 and then and the next one 32,000
so we're paying attention to this jump
here okay this jump from here to here
that's that's pretty pretty weird okay
the question is given this information
which element is this and why right it's
a period two element okay so which
element is this and why well if it's if
if that fourth ionization energy is
where it becomes really really high that
must mean that the ionization energy for
reaction is not trying to happen this is
not trying to happen at all so if we
think about it this reaction right is
not going to happen right doesn't want
to happen at least so that must mean
that must mean that this ion does not
want to give an electron it especially
does not want to give an another
electron up so this must mean this is
pretty stable it must mean it's super
stable okay because if it requires that
much more energy all right things are
super stable when they have filled outer
shells of electrons okay it must have a
filled outer shell of electrons
basically it probably has a noble gas
configuration so the question is now
which row to element loses three
electrons to have a noble gas
configuration right you can also ask
that question of which Row two element
has three outer shell electrons right
and its configuration would be helium
2s2 2p1 if we look on the periodic table
we'll find out that's boron right so
Boron's orbital diagram would be 2s2 2p1
and if it lost three electrons it would
lose all three of those and it would
have just helium's configuration it
would be b3 plus and it would just have
the one s2 right so that means that this
b 3 plus is representative
this X 3 + B 3 + if it had to lose an
electron would become B 4 + and then
that electron would leave right but that
would mean that this electron here this
electron would have to come from the 1s
orbital right so you'd be ruining the 1s
2 configuration that is helium's
configuration which is a noble gas
configuration and that is super super
stable and you would not want to rip
well this this ion would not want to
have that electron ripped off that would
be require tons and tons of energy
hence the ionization energy number 4 for
this reaction here is super high right
it equals that 25,000 26 kilojoules per
mole right it requires a same amount of
energy because your it would require
that amount of energy to ruin this
perfect configuration ok so which Row 2
element loses 3 electrons to have a
noble gas configuration
well it's boron right because if it
loses 3 electrons it has its noble gas
configuration it doesn't want to lose it
it doesn't want to lose another one and
that's why this fourth ionization energy
is so high relative to the third
ionization energy before it I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying